Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P a here is the eggman
weighing in about that. Right wingers were like
laughing at Joe Biden because he went to dinner
with Jill and they ordered the same on. It's
really weird. And the egg man called in about it.
Speaker 3: Hi, Dave. President Joseph biden
Junior and his wife Jill, went out to dinner
together. They ordered the same entree and
people are making fun of them for it or
they're being ripped apart, basically.
Speaker 1: I just spilled my water.
That's what happened, just so you know.
Speaker 3: For eating the same thing. And
I just want to say, I think that's adorable.
That's called, I don't know, love or some
kind of some kind of symbolic, I don't know,
something together. And I just want to ask, do
you think Trump even has a meal with his wife? No.
Speaker 1: No. Okay, so egg man weighing in on an
important issue. I couldn't possibly more strongly
defend Joe and Jill ordering the same entree. Now,
I think they had two different appetizers so
that there's that personally ordering the same
entree as my girlfriend is a no. And the reason
there's actually a really interesting article
that's called like the economics, The Economics
of Dining Out as a couple or something like
that. Yes. It's a Bloomberg article about seven
years old, the economics of dining as a couple.
And it explains that one of the great things one
of the great things about dining out as a couple
is you have the ability to sample multiple dishes.
It's very common that at a at a good restaurant,
there's more than one thing that you want. And
when will you be back? And it's a little bit,
you know, I'm not going to be ordering two
entrees, that's for sure. So what I like to
do is always order something different from
what my girlfriend gets so that we can share,
so that we can try it. And so sometimes I'll
say, you know, I'm thinking about I'm thinking
about getting the fish and chips, and she'll
say, I'm getting the fish and chips. I'm like,
Great. You get the fish and chips, I will
get something else. So now we can try the
fish and chips and we can try the other
thing as far as Joe and Joe Biden doing it,
more power to them. Absolutely more. I have no
problem in right wingers attacking them for it
is a joke. We've got a great bonus show for you
today. We are going to talk about Lori Lightfoot
losing her bid to remain mayor of Chicago. We are
going to talk about why Americans will lose $3
billion in food stamp benefits starting in March.
And Republicans seem to keep forgetting who the
president was in 2020. I'll tell you what I mean
on today's bonus show. Don't miss the bonus show
you can sign up at join Pacman dot com and you
will get instant access to the bonus show that
is hated by conspiracy theorist Alex Jones.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money. Yeah. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Join pacman dot com coupon
code 24 starts now. I'll see you next.